well you just saw the premiere of csi
vegas and now the i-team is showing us
inside the real las vegas csi as our
david charns found out it's not entirely
like the television show david no and as
i said during our six o'clock show i
forgot that we're talking hollywood here
the i-team did get exclusive access to
both csi and metro's forensics lab on
the show that you just saw they are one
but in real life they're two separate
departments working closely together
it's just one thing i found out that is
different here in the real world solving
some of the valley's most horrific
crimes
we're in some of the nastiest places
you'll ever go see here's real life
that's how las vegas metro police says
kristen gramis describes the real csi
the one she oversees from a nondescript
office park it is nothing like the show
if that's what you're getting at there's
no special lighting no high heels women
can't even wear their hair down so your
hair could fall out at a crime scene and
then you're collecting your own hair
so it's something that we don't do
there is not even a lab here in fact
unlike the tv show metro's csi unit and
the forensics lab are in separate
locations kimberly murga runs that side
of things i really wish our lives were
that exciting i really wish we could
solve crime in 60 minutes in reality
crimes can take months even years to
solve
gramas's crime scene analysts pick up
the evidence often working in and out of
this van that's the one you see out in
the field anything that maybe could link
to what happened and what occurred
pulling fingerprints checking for blood
trying to get any little thing a
criminal may have left behind including
their dna
on the day the i-team visited their
offices analysts were pulling prints off
soda cans left behind at a homicide the
victim's clothes hanging in this
specialized machine we want to preserve
that so we need to dry it as quickly as
possible
once evidence is packed it heads on over
to the labs vault what we do is exciting
behind the scenes but it takes time and
it's not resolved quickly there merga's
forensic scientists do all the tests
we're so accustomed to seeing on tv so
much evolving since the original csi
premiered 20 years ago one of the
biggest changes is in dna technology
merga says testing a blood stain the
size of a quarter used to take eight
weeks now her team can pull from the
size of a pinhead getting those results
in hours no matter the time frame the
end goal is figuring it out seeing not
only that those crimes are solved but
that justice is served
really cool to see all that so with csi
comes the so-called csi effect where
juries expect to see evidence from a
crime that they saw on the show that
actually doesn't exist and there's also
the abundance of people who want to work
on one of these teams you just saw but
you have to have a scientist degree and
also have special certifications denise
but really cool to see and i was just
sort of blown away by the fact that the
women have to put their hair up because
if their hair comes out you know
obviously strands of hair come out that
could ruin the crime scene that didn't
happen
on the show they're wearing the high
heels and all that stuff they can't they
can't do that yeah that was interesting
report thanks